un espoir de réconciliation moyen-orient
déjà mis à mal à l'occasion de la
campagne de vaccination
ce mardi le hamas mouvement palestinien
au pouvoir dans la bande de gaza a
dénoncé une violation criminelle du
droit international de la part d'israël
l'autorité palestinienne accuse en effet
l'état hébreu d'avoir bloqué l'entrée de
milliers de doses de vaccin pour lutter
contre le kobe de 19 à gaza qui compte
près de 2 millions d'habitants
c'est une mesure discriminatoire
un vrai crime est une violation de
toutes les lois internationales et
normes humanitaires le hamas en appelle
à la fin du blocus israélien autour de
la bande de gaza séparée
géographiquement de la cisjordanie un
blocus qui dure depuis une décennie qui
serait elle justifie par la présence du
mouvement armé hamas
l'état hébreu là sur l'entrée de vaccins
à gaza est à l'étude
la demande palestinienne d'entrée de
vaccin est en cours d'examen et attend
une décision politique
depuis le lancement de sa campagne de
vaccination début février l'autorité
palestinienne indique avoir reçu deux
mille doses de la part d'israël et dix
mille doses du vaccin spoutnik v grâce à
une subvention du gouvernement russe
le gouvernement palestinien condamne le
blocage des vaccins destinés à sa
population et en appelle à l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé doit
tenir israël comme pleinement
responsable des dangers liés à
l'interdiction d'entrée des vaccins à
gaza dans la bande de gaza plus de
cinquante trois mille cas ont été
enregistrés depuis le début de la
pandémie et 538 personnes sont décédées
du comique 19